this is a day in the life of a kildo
restaurant worker kensuke gets up at
7:30 each day and has toast and eggs for
breakfast then he brushes his teeth puts
on his waiter uniform gets on his bike
and rides to work a restaurant famous
for homo eel after he gets to the
restaurant he takes part in the morning
meeting from here he prepares for
customers taking food out of the freezer
preparing the ingredients for the Miso
soup and checking the dining area for
any garbage missed the night before at
10:30 the doors open and kensuke's real
work begins my gosh this restaurant is
so
fancy sorry what was that do you want
English menu or Japanese menu oh English
please excuse
me wow kensuke is already really busy so
is it okay to
order okay yeah I'll take the perer eel
set please okay oh me too
please is it always this
busy excuse
us do you have a table for five
five sorry please wait oh right
sure sorry can we go yes please follow
me oh great thank you so
much do you
order excuse us please wait
sorry
was speaking
English it better be good hi oh sorry we
asked for an English menu but got a
Japanese
one okay good luck
kensuke